[Musique]
vous êtes pour prendre la peine de mort
madame g6
c'est pas nous à juger les autres sa vie
tandis qu'un policier tous les cas je
suis contre senna range derrière les
gens qui donnent la mort là méritent
aussi si on est dans les prisons toute
la vie c'est peut-être pire que
j'appelle du nom vous êtes allé
l'occasion nous mêmes on les condamne
en effet face à paris quelle honte qui a
tué 20 ça dépend la circonstance du
crime est aussi celui qui a tué
quelqu'un thiam ans doit effectuer on
devrait le faire sont pacifiques et
d'exposer place de la concorde y aurait
moins de banditisme ce qu'on envoie le
reste je pense qu'il serait préférable
que
celui qui aurait assassiné travail
jusqu'à la fin de ses jours pour pouvoir
élever la famille de la victime
mais si quelqu'un d'autre en famille par
exemple du casa suédois dans les
commissions mardi sur y également contre
la mort de cinq ans même quand on les
condamne on les fait travailler toute sa
vie sur la société
mais j'ai dit que je suis pour la peine
de mort voilà il n'y a pas eu besoin de
souffler mais nous allons mais
simplement quelques conditions
évidemment qui sont valables tombe
réflexe plus que raisonnement la loi du
talion a gardé bien des partisans en
grande-bretagne l'opinion publique était
en majorité pour le maintien de la peine
capitale
en france en revanche le dernier sondage
de l'ifop en novembre 1969 a donné les
pourcentages suivants 33% pour la peine
de mort 58 % contre 9 % ne se prononçant
pas parmi les moins de 35 ans 64%
ils sont opposés boucherie n'est pas
digne du 20e siècle
autant je comprends qu'une mère de
famille dont l'enfant a été créée puisse
avoir envie de te les assassins autant
je comprends que n'importe qui qui perd
un être cher assassiné puisse avoir
envie de se venger
fan mais on tente mais pas que deux
sociétés qui n'a pas pris parti dans cet
affreux drame
deux ans après trois ans après l'ondé
matters gmt un homme qui n'est qu'un
nombre d'elle-même qu'elle nous disait
il a testé station intime la société -
quel point ils se détestent se méprisent
et se coupe un arbre
elle avoue son impuissance qu'elle
cherche un autre code qu'elle enferme
l'homme qu'elle fasse tout pour protéger
la société
j'ai souscrit qu'elle ne tue plus la
civilisation l'humanisme l'exigent ce
vin ce problème de la peine de mort pour
des causes ou motivation si diverse
comporte un certain nombre de questions
vers quelle est exactement la position
c'est une question je dirais de
gouvernement n'est ce pas église
elle-même dans toute cette théologie des
toujours que le principe de libyens
général qui domine le bien particulier
doit être en tout et partout mines en
vigueur alors si dans un corps
particulier un corps social un monde
rêvant grainé et bien elle laisse au
gouvernement le soin de se séparer de ce
membre gangréné exactement comme un
chirurgien amputera le droit d'une
personne qui à l'avant-bras être la
peine capitale pour les hommes dont le
devoir est de représenter la société ou
de la défendre est un douloureux cas de
conscience
monsieur le président vous avez été
appelé a énoncé un certain nombre de
sentences capitales
oui pas beaucoup fort heureusement dans
en italie présidence chez durand
prononcer peut-être une dizaine et j'ai
eu deux exécutions celle de buisson la
nuit public nîmes 2 1 et celle de frêche
c'est le président est ce que vous vous
personnellement vous êtes pour ou contre
la peine de mort moi je dirais qu en
tant qu ancien magistrat l'ancien
président de cour d'assises
il m'est difficile de me mettre à la
tête d'une croisade contre la peine de
mort je n'ai pas d'une croisade
elle est inscrite dans la loi il m'est
arrivé de l'appliquer comme je voulais
dit très rarement mais je ne peux pas
alors ce que les votes sont émis
m'opposer à ce que la sanction soit
prononcée
mais vous personnellement moi
personnellement j'ai le secret
professionnel de ce cas des libérations
mais je puis vous dire que après la
condamnation
nous faisons un rapport à la
chancellerie qui est remis à un
président de la république dans laquelle
nous concluons soir de la justice suit
son cours soit que nous comblons une
commutation de peine je n'ai jamais dans
ma carrière demander autre chose qu une
commutation de peine en faveur du canada
l'argument essentiel des partisans du
maintien de la peine capitale et celui
de l'exemplarité de la sentence
il fait abstraction de l'interrogation
fondamentale sur le droit de décider
délibérément de la mort d'homme il est
le plus controversé
ar je crois personnellement profondément
à l'exemplarité de la peine une heure je
sais bien que les abolitionnistes n'y
croit pas et la principal argument
consiste à sortir des statistiques
qu'ils empruntent un certain nombre de
pays étrangers
tout d'abord en super gt une contrée par
le chiffre auquel vous montrer la
chinoise qui progresse dans les crises
abolitionnistes tous ont dû accueillir 3
d'armentières qui croyant encore un
déclic en emploi et le mental la peine
de mort le fausse sécurité commenté
boudreau attention nous allons tout ça
fins de conservation et c'est la raison
pour laquelle la mort le risque d'être
enrayée la biotine un petit matin fait
même peur aux gens et c'est la seule
chose vraiment bien que l'on songe à la
défense de la société
je pense qu'en conscience quand ils
s'entendent comme celle ci est formulée
il ya tout de même un moment difficile
oui particulièrement pénible parce que
nous sommes obligés de faire savoir la
cuisine condamné à mort il aurait
peut-être tranché la maison d'arrêt de
la santé
ça passe difficilement deuxièmement
présentes assises à l'obligation
impérative d'assister à l'exécution
c'est lui qui signait le procès-verbal
d'exécution qui est affiché sur la porte
de la maison d'arrêt de la santé
mon père vous avez assisté à combien
d'exécution grande 324 en a 24 ans lui
il ya tout de même au petit matin et
s'enquiert de sentimentalisme des
moments assez dure c'est dur très dur
parce que on les aime malgré tout va dès
lors faut il ya toujours un point qui
est aimable et chez aucun d'entre eux je
n'ai rencontré le mal dans toutes leurs
heures du terme s'il ya toujours eu un
point sympathique chez eux
puis vous n'êtes pas auprès de quelqu'un
attend dé moi ou pas dans le mode
souffrent en difficulté pour eux s'en
sont fortement sachetat chez eux mais
alors n'est pas le moment pour moi qui
ai le plus critique
c'est le moment du réveil le détenu gelé
formé pendant de longs mois
quelque chose mais c'est surtout qu'il
est là fait en lui
j'y suis arrivé aucun des condamnés à
mort au moment leur exécution
le s'est révolté contre cette veine une
exécution
le présumé coupable suivra celle 11
étroit couloir avant de découvrir la
salle impressionnante où il aura rang de
vedettes de l'actualité
[Musique]
la tête du bob va jouer son physique
l'actualité s'il n'ya rien aspects sous
la dent ce jour là la presse affaires à
un monde du crime qu'on vient de
commettre du procès qui commence
le président va jouer un rôle il est
bousculé répressif ou un d'une jambe
paternel
l'avocat général a du talent on en a pas
ils répressif ou non l'avocat est bon ou
mauvais les jurés personne c'est ce
qu'ils sont dix ans et il quels
problèmes sont-ils dans le procès dure
deux jours ils rentrent chez eux le soir
leur samedi à lens et vilains
j'espère qu'ils y passent au bistrot du
coin on dit d'un ton client là j'espère
que la guillotine jury revient le
lendemain d une tête nouvelle avec une
morale reçu avec texture ajouté vous
savez les témoins ou sortent ils
pourront ils être vous avez enfin
quelque chose d'effroyable c'est cette
espèce de personnages qu'à mille
couleurs me revêtement anti président
commandes qui requiert qui plaide qui
est le hasard et je dis que si à la même
heure dans 90 cours d'assises françaises
ont jugé le même homme il n'aurait pas
90 fois la peine de mort ça tranche
onema une expérience a été faite à un
numéro à un sujet c'est moi qui l'ait
fait
j'ai apporté en effet le dossier d'un de
mes clients condamnés à mort et exécutés
on a démarqué pour la géographie par le
temps les dates levin et cetera on a
fait un réquisitoire qui était la
reproduction de celui qui fut prononcé
une plaidoirie la reproduction de celle
que j'avais prononcé on appris des vrais
jurer avec l'autorisation de monsieur
michelet garde des sceaux à l'époque qui
avait imposé que les trois magistrats
seraient présumé avoir voté tous les
trois la mort est nul paris on a enfermé
les jurés ils ont délibéré
et on a eu des résultats strasbourg
peine de mort lille perpétuité boîtier
20 ans versailles perpétuité cherbourg
perpétuité c'est fini on avait gagné
et quand je pense que mon malheureux
clients étaient déjà morts et enterrés
dans sa caisse à claire vous achetez au
hasard coupé en deux dans un cimetière
sans croix je dis que c'est affreux que
le hasard est ainsi tués est ainsi rayée
des humains dans des conditions qui
était fait du hasard
on perd ou ne croyez pas que sur le plan
humain on courait tout même
envisager autre chose que d'envisager
autre chose bien sûr mais pas tout le
monde tout le monde est content
sentimentalement parlant tour des
contres une peine pareil c'est pas et
des glyphes aurait trouvé quelque chose
avant de pouvoir l'assumer
moi je trouve que étant donné la
psychologie actuelle qui a beaucoup
avancé comme science il est
incontestable pourrait créer des centres
spéciaux je ne dirais même pas dépenser
je dirais des centres où l'on pour
prendre une mentalité avec des
psychologues avec des gens qui
connaissent le coeur de l'individu et
voyez vous c'est là où se situe ce que
je disais à propos de l'aumônier de
prison qui n'est pas un oeuf de
s'occuper d'un point de vue social ou
d'un point de vue d'organisation de
telle ou telle affaire de justice mais
le coeur de l'individu par delà la
question sociale qu il faut pas d'abord
les exclure de la société des assassins
ça c'est mon sentiment profond dans le
temps les l'hébreu les lépreux été mis
sur une île hors contact avec toute la
société
on pourrait peut-être envisager une
solution pareil des maîtres danger nil
avec les formes l artisanat les rendre
quand même utile d'essayer de les
réadapter
parce que dans tout dans tout criminel
il ya des ponts ciel bleu il suffirait
d'une triste affaire dans les prochains
jours pour que soit à retourner une
opinion publique dans l'ensemble
favorables actuellement à l'abolition
c'est une grave question que chacun doit
juger en conscience mais qui au plan
moral humain médicale judiciaire mérite
dans tous les cas d'être revus dans une
société moderne
[Musique]